was there
okay i'm going to be like a dumb person
but how much of i like someone that
checks their phone
yes
are you still catholic uh
i'm afraid that's all we have time my
parents my parents are my parents are
watching yeah uh
yeah you know yeah yeah you know yeah
commonly is the homie yo
could you work in popping and popping
and then and then yours will just be
everyone left yo everyone [ __ ] with
john molina here you go even better even
better i don't know everybody not in the
midwest but you know my mom will be like
who [ __ ] with you
[Laughter]
i i i do a thing when i'm nervous to
calm myself down me too what do you do
does it work
[Music]
please stop doing that please stop doing
it
i'm trying to make a gift
it was like so sexual and like i was
there like the last musical we'd seen
was like joseph and the amazing
technical drink
and now just watching this like oh my
god and my dad was like um
yeah suddenly two people are having sex
and they're just like
do you want some popcorn
i want to see this oh what's that a
chair
so many funny people and then no one did
bits the entire time
yes i think you know the gravity of a
situation
when fred armisen is not doing a bit
fred was serious do you know how
off-putting that is yeah
fred was like hey john i'm really
worried about what you're going i was
like
stop stop
i start to perform stand-up comedy okay
and one guy yelled from the back what is
the best heckle i've ever heard in my
life really he yelled excuse me sir i
think i speak for everyone here when i
say that we would enjoy silence more
than the sound of your voice
what yes
i saw you and i was already a huge fan
from uh strangers with candy in the
daily show but this was in the age
before cell phones so i couldn't get a
picture so i just went hey
so i got a call uh and i said hello you
know and
um they said they're good for you though
yeah
good improvising already absolutely
nothing fancy ordinary hello
yeah everyone i'm going john mulaney
checks into rehab for alcohol and
cocaine abuse and then the photo is of
me in those sunglasses yeah uh maybe
this one ranting this is a guy who's
about to show yeah that's a guy
that's a guy moments and his friend just
laughing in ignorance
i had high psychosexual self-esteem as a
kid
i don't remember when i learned the the
word but i remember watching l.a law
with my mother and there was there was a
female female kiss and she looked over
to be like how should i explain this and
i was like they're lesbians i know
that's a place murfreersboro
it was i think it was named by a dying
confederate general as he barely sat up
in bed eating mashed potatoes
and his grandson was like papi you got
to name the town and he was like more
for our bar
they're like put it on the sign
[Laughter]
like people go you're thin but i'm like
i know where the fat is it's hidden
in weird pockets where is your fat
specifically well my body's like the
apartment of a drug dealer like at first
you're like there's no cash here but
then you like tear open the couch and
there's nine hundred thousand
this is from charlie glad you were able
to stall all that time to get to that
joke why don't you shut up why don't you
shut up when all said and done
wasn't a joke
why don't you shut up ever
i've never taught i've never talked to
such an idiot person in my life
have you ever thought like idiot at the
end of a sentence but you don't say it
like it's right over there
well you can't marry everyone who's nice
because then you'd be married to too
many people
that's what i say that's exactly when i
speak at schools
they swim in the scene they swim in the
sea they have mustaches
famous baseball player blank hunter
it's an mtv show
i am so glad oh
oh they go meow and then they're fish
catfish oh my god oh my god
psychedelic mushrooms
yeah like how many times yeah you uh are
you
no not
not recently not in my adult life no
no little mullany tripped you
no i haven't done them in years
i haven't done them in uh years
all right i feel like you've done them
uh when i was about 11 years old i went
to a diner that had a jukebox where for
uh one dollar you got three plays and uh
my friend and i put in seven dollars and
then we selected 21 plays of tom jones's
what's new pussycat
hell i think it's an encyclopedia and
you can just look up what everyone in
your life thought about you
and if there is a heaven it's a
wikipedia and you can just change that
and he played what's new pussycat 22
times
for 45 minutes blasting over the school
intercom and they had to cancel school
is he expelled no he got suspended for
three days and he couldn't go to prom
[Music]
i'm driving to the clippers game with my
friend i won't say his name is nick
kroll so we're dropping
and i had one smoked pot with him and
then walked through the comedy store and
i had this really nice night i never
smoked pot so i
am very sensitive to when i do right so
uh he was like do you want a hit of this
i was like yes because i had such a nice
night at the comedy store i smoke it i
hand it back to him and he goes oh this
is not the same stuff from the comedy
store so i was like oh no
and then i was like where are our seats
he's like i didn't tell you they're
courtside so
i was super high
sitting
courtside uh the guy that plays jamie
lannister was like
nick and i bought the biggest thing of
popcorn we could buy
i ate all of it in the first quarter
and then uh the cheerleaders who are
fantastic like they go to different
sides of the court they're dancing right
in front of me so i'm so high and
paranoid and i'm trying to think like
how do i
like because i wanna
i wanna look appreciative
but not leering
so there was this whole torment in my
mind of like by the end i think i was
going
you are a you're a sharp dresser i
didn't know you went this casual because
i uh
i feel like i'm your like business
manager
we should talk about an estate plan i
know
no matter who the mayor of new york is
we hate him and then by the time he goes
we're like that's the mayor we love him
you know like bloomberg we hate it he'd
he'd be on he'd come out and like cover
the city in beige carpeting and then be
like shoes off and we'd be like ah
and then by the time he left we were
like it's my bloomberg and now now we
hate him again it's like it's a cycle
you actually glossed over one of my
favorite parts is because i sometimes go
to those beaches you know you just go
and you thought it would be fun to
propose on the beach yeah we had been at
a beach so we're from new york you know
i don't know the layout that well in la
i know that malibu is nice from the 80s
so
i was i thought what's nicer than
something that was nice a long time ago
so i
i drove with my uh fiance anna or my
girlfriend at that moment and i went to
this beach uh off the pch next to this
restaurant called gladstones now in
fairness to me we had been at that beach
a couple weeks ago and the sun was
setting and it was beautiful you know
and i thought if i had a ring i'd
propose right now on the day that i took
her the beach was i don't know how to
phrase this crawling with homeless
people
literally like one person like in the
beginning of monty python holy grail was
just digging in sand
angrily trying to dig to china and
we started walking
and you know and part of me was like is
this funny
if i propose here
we're walking there's a guy and we get
to a point where i'm like i think in the
next 10 yards we might have some clear
space
we might have a window a window between
maniacs
and then a shirtless man walks to the
edge of the ocean and goes
and anna said there are a lot of other
beaches in malibu and i said that's
right and so we got back in the car and
we drove way further down to another yes
yes oh my god so she was wise she was
very wise i mean she knew i'm using it
like the she knew i was gonna propose
yeah do you remember how she knew
[Applause]
no she knew what was up because i was
like
you know we gotta look it was all it was
a disaster i got on
we started driving and i said we're not
going to the airport you know i thought
we'd spend one more day in la and like i
have never
done any kind of surprise before so
right away it was just dead silence in
the car and she was like okay
and then it takes a while to get from
those feelers to malibu apparently so
we sat in silence in the car
luckily my manager kept calling to say
my pilot hadn't been picked up
[Applause]
no it was worth it it was totally it was
really funny it was so tense and then
when i proposed it was really worth